the organizers in this fantastic
workshop I'm going to talk about ways to
get statistical privacy in witness
indistinguishable argument systems this
is based on two joint works the first is
with the I local I and omit Sahai who
are both here or Yale was here and the
next is and this one gets a
statistically witness indistinguishable
arguments in the privately verifiable
setting the the next one is improves
upon this result in some ways to get
w-why arguments in the publicly
verifiable setting and this is joint
work with Sai Krishna bhajan are einen
Rex Fernando and I use Jane who are all
students at UCLA and Amit Sahai who's
also at UCLA and who's here and so I'm
I'm going to focus on interactive proofs
for NP languages in this talk where the
prover has input and instance and a
witness and the verifier has input and
instance when the Provo wants to
convince the verifier that this instance
is in the language so we all know what
these are because the entire workshop
has been about these but what what I
want to focus on is the two methods
setting and the standard properties that
we want from such a proof system are
completeness which means that if X is in
the language and the prover behaves
honestly the verify should accept and
soundness which says that if X is not in
the language then the prover then the
then no matter what the prover does the
verifier should reject the proof with
overwhelming probability no I will
clarify that though in a minute and
another property that we typically want
out of proof systems is some sort of
privacy zero knowledge unfortunately is
impossible in this two message setting
unless we rely on a trusted set up which
we don't want to do what is known to be
possible is a weaker yet simple property
called witness indistinguishability this
this guarantees that the view of a
malicious verifier that interacts with
in with
prove er does not reveal to the verifier
the witness that the prover is using
this makes sense for languages for
instances that have more than one
witness and the guarantee is that the
view of the verifier participating in
Game one where the prover uses witness W
one should be indistinguishable from its
view in Game two when the prover is
using witness W two and so far existing
proof systems have been secured against
only bounded or probabilistic
polynomial-time verifiers
and most have been secured against
unbounded provers which means they can
satisfy statistical soundness but they
are not statistically witness
indistinguishable and so non
constructions are based on trapdoor
permutations by linear maps and more
recently on IO and one way functions in
this setting with an unbounded prover
and a bounded verifier and these are
extensively used in various primitives
and protocols however they all suffer
from one strong limitation or one
important limitation which is that
privacy is not everlasting so none of
these existing constructions are secure
if the verifier after completing the
proof runs his computer for ten years
and tries to break the WI property and
also existing constructions are not post
quantum security i wantam computer gets
built in the meanwhile they become
insecure
oh no they're they're not no they are
secure with respect to all seas
oh I mean exponential run time it's just
not everlasting so if someone ran their
machine for long enough and did let's
say yes it's only computation
if the Assumption gets broken after the
protocol finishes running then you're in
trouble if you want the assumption to
you want the assumption oh you're so
just fine so you want witness
indistinguishability to be independent
of the assumption that you're using and
maybe use the assumption only to
guarantee soundness in a case where the
prover is bounded and the verifier can
run in unbounded time and maybe try to
break the assumption and the reason that
this could be more desirable sometimes
is that soundness is typically required
to be an online property so if the
proven yes now I'm just saying that well
while she prefers the zero knowledge to
the Sun is to be computational suppose
of the other way around
yes
so if at the time of running the proof
your assumption is secure then having
approval be bounded makes more sense
than having the verifier requiring the
verifier of militias verified to be
bounded and so known constructions in
this setting basically before the works
that I'm going to talk about well did
not exist so what I will talk about are
two results that get statistical witness
indistinguishability one is in a joint
work with alkali and emits a high and
gives to message WI in the privately
verifiable setting and using some tools
from this work together with some tools
from recent work on instantiate increa
c'mere we get you know in a joint work
with but Gina Ryan and Fernando Jen and
I'm excited we get from publicly
verifiable to message statistically
witness indistinguishable arguments and
this same result was achieved in a
concurrent work by Abhishek Jen and zero
engine and and so these are more a
little more in detail the two results
that I'll tell you about are that one in
the privately verifiable setting a
statistical wi arguments exist
assuming quasi-polynomial hardness of
two message OT which can in turn be
instantiated from DDH quarreled accuracy
diversity and threats adversity lwe etc
and then the other theorem that i will
talk about is that two message publicly
verifiable statistical wi arguments
exist assuming the quasi-polynomial
hardness of the learning with errors
assumption this is also the first
construction of zaps or publicly
verifiable to message wi from lattice
based assumptions and there is another
concurrent work of Lombardy where could
- Nathan and vixx who obtained
computational WI arguments from lattice
based assumptions so their result is not
statistically WI but it is also the
first post quantum Zapp yes
substituted a verifier than any old like
statistical mr. yes so yes this is mr.
Smith queuing face when you're a lot of
the very fire to descend Monsieur honest
verify yeah honestly what percent
something malicious rather so we care
about the malicious verifier
and talk to you about Italy so the
starting point for both of these
constructions is a natural Sigma
protocol which and we start with a
variant of the 3-round WI proof for
graph hamiltonicity due to Blum where
the prover has a graph G and wanted to
prove to the verifier that this graph
has a Hamiltonian cycle the prover
simply commits to a permutation on this
graph and the permutation and on input a
challenge either D commits to the entire
permuted graph and reveals the
permutation proving that he computed
this permutation correctly or D commits
to the edges of the permutation of the
Hamiltonian cycle in this permeated
graph and I am sure many of you are
already familiar with this but the
reason that I'm using this specific
example here is because it satisfies a
certain property this property is that
for every message sent by a potentially
malicious prover there exists a single
challenge on which the prover can
convince the verifier to accept the
proof if X is not in the language
and moreover this single challenge is an
efficiently computable function of the
value that lies inside the commitments
generated by the prover in the first
round so for instance approver that
commits to for instance for a graph that
does not have a Hamiltonian cycle
approval can either convincingly commit
to a permutation on this graph or commit
to a random graph that has a Hamiltonian
in it but once he is committed there is
exactly one bad challenge on which the
prover can D commit and for so verify to
accept when X is not in the language
this is a variant of the property that
is also used in other recent Faramir
type compilers and based on this okay so
based on this property we ideally want
to sorry it's just stated a little
differently in those compilers
so you need that this challenge is
unique yes there is a unique challenge
that is efficiently computable if one
gives you the values that were inside
the commitment and so so this is clearly
just computationally witness
indistinguishable and does not have
satisfy any guarantees against an
unbounded verifier so the first thing
that we will do is modify it into a
statistically witness indistinguishable
argument by replacing the commitment
used by the prover with a statistically
hiding commitment so this will just be a
two message statistically hiding
commitment and the rest of the protocol
remains the same but now this modified
protocol does not satisfy that property
that I just talked about because if the
commit if a commitment is statistically
hiding an unbounded prover can open it
many different ways and there is no
single challenge then that would allow a
cheating approval to cause the verifier
to accept the proof and instead all
challenges or most challenges would have
responses that an unbounded prover could
compute for single verifier to accept
such a proof so but this is still the
broad template that we will use and we
will show how to instantiate this
chopper template with a special type of
statistically hiding commitment in order
to allow for the Fiat Samiha type
compiler to work so using this template
we we obtain both to message privately
verifiable statistical wi and publicly
verifiable statistical wi the privately
verifiable result relies on compressing
this four message modified Blom argument
using the BMW heuristic and oblivious
transfer to get a two message argument
and i'm not going to go into too many
details of that here i will focus on the
other one i just want to say a few
things about this compression so this is
known to work for proof systems and we
make it work for certain types of
arguments like the modified bloom
argument that I just described and this
heuristic necessarily only gives private
verifiability so to get publicly
verifiable state
testicle WI the heuristic that we use
and instantiate is the Faramir heuristic
where we take again the modified blum
protocol and have decluttered notation
here to remove the permutation and graph
representation etc but we should just
remember that this is actually the
Graham Blum protocol and then the Future
made heuristic says that this can be
compressed by using a hash function so
that the prover in addition to providing
the first message of the statistically
hiding commitment also provides a hash
key and then the sorry sorry the
verifier in addition to providing the
first message of the statistically
hiding commitment also provides the hash
key and then the prover responds to this
commitment committing to his values
computes a challenge by applying the
hash on the commitment transcript so far
and then based on this challenge D
commits to certain parts of the
committed value so think of this as a
parallel repetition of many modified
blum protocols that's just been
compressed using the Faramir heuristic
and you don't need any property and it
on the monitor promise right
so we're going to show how to
instantiate it with the real world
so two tools will help us prove
soundness of this compressed
construction the first is a special type
of a statistically hiding commitment
scheme and the second is a correlation
intractable hash function the
correlation intractable hash that we use
specifically is the one is a quasi
polynomially secure variant of the one
constructed based on lwe very recently
by peickert and Shahan so what is a
correlation intractable hash these were
first introduced by cornetti Gould Reich
and her Levy and these are defined with
respect to a function family and can
also be generalized to relations between
only care about them with respect to
functions in this world and they consist
of two algorithms there's a set of
algorithm that on input a function from
this family generates a hash key and an
evaluation algorithm that on input a
hash key and value X outputs some value
Y the property is that these algorithms
satisfy our correlation intractability
which requires that for every function
in the family the probability that an
adversary given a hash key that was
generated by running the setup algorithm
on this function so the probability that
an adversary given this hash key outputs
an X such that hash of x equals f of X
is negligible what this means is that it
should be difficult to find an X such
that hash of x equals f of X for each
generated by running the setup on
function f and the second property is
indistinguishability of hash keys which
basically just requires that the hash
key hide the function f that was used to
generate it why is this useful so there
so before talking about why this is
useful I let me just point out a bunch
of recent constructions that have
obtained correlation interactable hash
functions for various families of
functions based on different assumptions
so there was the work of kinetic chain
raisin and Roth blue and then the work
of Holmgren and Lombardi that obtained
these hash functions based on various
less standard assumptions and then more
recently there is
the work of kinetic chain Holmgren
Lombardi rod Blum Roth bloomin face as
well as the works of piccata and she Han
got constructions of correlation
intractable hash functions based on
circular secure effigy and then plain
lwa respectively and borrowing and and
they used these to get the first
constructions of non-interactive zero
knowledge from plain lwe so borrowing
from their ideas let's see what happens
when we try to instantiate the hash
function in ARCA in our Faramir
compression with a correlation in
tractable hash function suppose this
correlation in tractable hash had the
property that for every commitment
script string there is at most so sorry
suppose the suppose our scheme had the
property that for every commitment
scheme there is at most one bad
challenge such that the prover can even
compute an accepting answer on this
challenge what we would then do is we
would set our function f for the
correlation intractable hash family to
be that bad challenge and by the
property of the correlation intractable
hash we would have the guarantee that H
of X is not equal to f of X and
therefore the prover wouldn't be able to
cheat
unfortunately a statistically hiding
commitment like I said does not give us
this property for free and there's an
even bigger problem which is that the
function f that we want to set to be due
to be the one that computes our bad
challenge is not an efficiently
computable function of the value that's
being committed sorry yeah of the value
that's being committed actually that
doesn't even make sense here necessarily
because this is a statistically hiding
commitment that just loses the value
that's being committed information
theoretical so so our learning from this
is that we need to design a special type
of statistically hiding commitment
scheme that makes the function f
efficiently computable some of the time
and gives us the required property that
we want which is that the function f
which which is this property that for
every a and B there is at most one bad
challenge and we will design a
commitment that also gives us this
property some of the time so what do I
mean by giving us this property some of
the time well the the concrete object
that we will use is a to message
statistically hiding extractable
commitment scheme so this was introduced
and first constructed in this first
paper on privately verifiable WI and
then we modified it for use in the
publicly verifiable setting so a to make
a statistically hiding extractable
commitment is a two message commitment
scheme that is in the plain model that
satisfies statistical hiring and
computational binding and moreover it is
extractable now again extract ability
sounds like a contradiction to the
statistical hiding property of a two
message scheme but the reason that this
is not a contradiction is that we design
a commitment that operates in two modes
one is an extractable mode where the
hiding guarantee does not hold and one
is the regular hiding mode where which
is statistically hiding and the the
commitment operates in extractable mode
with only a very small probability
so even when it is in extractable mode
the statistical hiding property still
holds because it is in non extractable
statistically hiding mode most of the
time with probability 1 minus Epsilon
yes if you use the commitment scheme
that's computationally industry from one
- this is a binding yes so you would
want something that from the point of
view of the prover is indistinguishable
from one that's computationally that's
statistically binding and that is kind
of the property that we design so
[Music]
exactly the next thing I was going to
say which is that the committers should
not be able to tell what mode the scheme
is in so that he cannot break soundness
in one mode and not break soundness in
the other and moreover the receiver
should not be able to set the scheme to
be extractable all the time because then
that would violate statistical hiding
what we want to do this without a CLS
and so what we will do is have both of
them decide what mode the commitment
operates in so how do we get both of
them to decide this well we get them to
implement an erasure channel so what
does this ratio channel do it takes the
committers input and transmits it to the
receiver with only a small probability
epsilon and with the remaining 1 minus
epsilon probability this channel just
information theoretically erases the
message and it's crucial for our proofs
to work that the committee doesn't know
whether or not the message m got
transmitted
that's what that's the kind of a racial
channel that we will try to implement
unfortunately these don't exist in the
plane model so what we will do is we
will rely on statistically sender
private oblivious transfer in order to
implement this statistically send a
private oblivious transfer scheme is one
where a sender has two messages m0 and
m1 and an unbounded receiver has input a
choice bit and they run a two message
oblivious transfer protocol at the end
of which the receiver gets the CH
message of the center the security
properties that we want out of these are
that the sender should not know what the
choice bit of the receiver is and an
unbounded receiver should not learn the
other message it should not delay learn
any information about the other message
of the sender which is the one that he
chose not to receive that's written out
more formally here and there are known
constructions of such statistically
centered private of livius transfer
based on the decisional diffie-hellman
assumption the quadratic residue versity
and the entry diversity assumption as
well as their learning with errors
assumption the first is due to now land
Pinker's the second is due to Halevy and
kalaiy and very recently recur ski and
dawdling constructed this based on the
lwe assumption so using this oblivious
transfer we're going to implement an
erasure channel between the committer
and the receiver in a way that forces
the committer to transmit his message
with probability at least epsilon and
forces the receiver to not receive this
message with probability anymore than
epsilon and the way we will do this is
that the receiver will choose a random
challenge which is going to be n bits
long
this n is going to allow us to control
the probability that the receiver with
which the receiver gets the message the
receiver will then construct an OT
message using this challenge that so for
every I the receiver will send an OT
message where his choice bit is going to
correspond to the ayats bit of this
challenge
the committer is going on input message
m samples
string that is n bits long and encodes
his message in in the following way so
he creates a matrix where all entries in
this matrix are random except for except
that the entries are at sorry except
that the entries in this matrix that are
indexed by the bits of our eggs or to
the actual message so if the random
string is 0 1 0 rather than the first
then in this two-dimensional array m10
ex-ored with m2 1 and so forth is going
to be the actual message what this
guarantees is that the message M is
secret shared between n parts and the
probability that the receiver gets the
message M actually corresponds to the
probability that he guessed all these n
parts correctly so let me just complete
the scheme first the committer sends in
the clear this value R as well as
oblivious transfers that transmit the
messages both messages at every index
are at the end of this the receiver just
gets the messages corresponding to his
challenge string which means that he
gets the right message so the receiver
gets the right message if and only if
the receivers child in string happens to
be equal to the random value chosen by
the sender the probability that this
happens is we can prove that the
probability that this happens is close
to what you would expect which is
roughly 1 by 2 to the N because the
oblivious transfer message hides the
receivers challenge and the committer
even if he chooses are maliciously
cannot bias our to be equal or not equal
to the challenge with probability better
than what you would expect
the scheme is also statistically hiding
whenever the challenge is not equal to
our and this follows by the statistical
sender privacy property of the ER key
because the OT just loses all the
messages where the where the ayats bit
of the challenge was not equal to the I
admit of our that was chosen by the
coming
and most importantly the committer here
cannot tell whether or not his challenge
equals the randomness are that was
sampled by the receiver and this is
because the challenge of the receiver is
hidden computationally by the obvious
transport which is why this soundness
guarantee is only called is only going
to be computational looking ahead
so that completes our construction of
statistically hiding extractable
commitments in order to get epsilon to
something like 1 by K to the law okay
we're going to just set our the length
of these challenge and random strings to
be something like log square K okay
being the security parameter and this is
going to guarantee that the two that CH
and R are roughly going to be equal with
probability 1 by K to the log K which
corresponds to X tractable mode for the
commitment and the remaining probability
will contribute to the hiding property
of the commitment ok so now next let's
sorry ok so next let's use this to try
to instantiate future me now
even so so the first thing that we do is
make our statistically hiding commitment
a statistically hiding extractable
commitment and we make our hash a
correlation intractable hash and then we
use the statistically hiding extractable
property to argue that if approval
breaks soundness with probability 1 over
bali when the commitment is in normal
mode then the prover must also continue
to break soundness with probability 1 by
Polly well conditioned on being in
extraction mode and the reason this is
true is because the commitment has this
guarantee that the committer
doesn't know what mode he is operating
in so if soundness holes-in-one mode it
must also hold in the other and next we
will use the fact that soundness holds
in extractable mode in order to are in
order to argue that the correlation in
or in order to argue that the prover
breaks correlation intractability of the
hash function with this epsilon over
Pali probability and get a contradiction
to the correlation intractability of the
house
this is just as you would expect and it
turns out that even though this is a
really low probability event it still
suffices to get a contradiction if we
set our parameters for the correlation
interactable has carefully enough
there are many subtleties that happen
when instantiate when arguing the formal
proof according to this template and the
the first thing that we need to do is to
carefully set the function f that allows
us to compute this bad challenge in
order to contradict correlation and
tractability we also need to set other
parameters carefully enough to ensure
that statistical hiding and soundness
work to work well together
one other subtlety that arises is that
our proof requires us to get some n
number of pol n number of commitments
where n is a polynomial in the security
parameter that are all jointly
extractable with probability that does
not grow that that is independent of n
so that does not grow exponentially
small as n grows large and the reason
that we need that is because we need it
it turns out that when we set various
parameters carefully we need a certain
number of parallel repetitions to
guarantee a certain level of soundness
that dictates the number the number of
commitments and that we need and to
ensure that that fits in properly with
the correlation and tractability of the
hash function family we need them to be
jointly extractable with this
probability
notice that the construction that I just
described does not does not easily
directly extend to satisfy this property
because we just constructed one
commitment that was extractable with
probability 1 by K to the log K and if
you blindly extend it to create n
commitments then the probability that
you extract from all n of those is going
to grow exponentially small in n so this
needs to be done in a somewhat careful
way and then let me just conclude with
some open problems the first is can we
obtain two message statistical witness
indistinguishable protocol
based on polynomial assumptions so note
that both approaches that I referred to
today make crucial use of statistically
hiding extractable commitments which
inherently requires super polynomial
time assumptions so can we do without
those assumptions and another question
is can we get new compilers for other
types of Sigma protocols that do not
follow this specific template where they
exist this one bad challenge that allows
you to get a contradiction and can we
make those work also in the statistical
setting that concludes my talk thank you
[Applause]
could you reuse the first message yes
can you reuse the first one yes I think
in the publicly verifiable setting you
can like if I can learn the answer it's
publicly verifiable so that's a but it's
it's not as it is it's only adaptively
found a few leverage parameters of
sufficiently so that the hardness of
your language is less than the hardness
of the OT that you use to get the
receiver message
yes to catch Amir together an
insufficient our stuff also works as
long as the number is not the same thing
I think you need polynomially many bad
challenges polynomials would work great
any polynomial that would also its yeah
that would that would work even for us
in the privately verifiable setting also
we rely on this one by charing properly
actually for soundness it's possible
that that can be extended in some other
[Applause]